you can tell tensions are running very
high within Donald Trump's inner circle
because of the start of this impeachment
inquiry against him and Donald Trump's
lawyer Rudy Giuliani went on TV
yesterday and absolutely lost it
starting to call the other guests a
[ __ ] and I get it everything is coming
crashing down around the Trump
administration they are panicked they
are now planning to put out what is
effectively the bar letter 2.0 I'll talk
to you about that in the next segment
with regard to the transcript of trumps
phone call with the Ukrainian president
in July so I understand why this is
happening check this out look at the
abuse that Rudy Giuliani Trump's lawyer
hurls at his fellow guests on Fox News's
Laura Ingraham program the person Rudy
Giuliani is attacking here is Chris Hahn
who's a former aide to Democratic
Senator Chuck Schumer clearly Rudy is
not pleased with him take a look at this
irresponsible choice yeah well you
actually usually say incredibly stupid
thing you're a public figure yeah and by
the way do you have any idea that the
State Department know what you're
talking about idiot I do the state no
you don't you just lie I wish it would
stop you lied stop this would stop why
don't you tell him to keep his mouth
shut so we can tell the truth just keep
lying mouth respond okay he said now for
a while Rudy Giuliani was known for
drinking before going on evening
television shows that he would appear on
and it was a big problem for a while
people are in the around Trump or trying
to keep Rudy Giuliani on daytime shows
because he wouldn't be drinking before
those at least not not often I don't
know if that was a factor here but
yelling shut up [ __ ]
the day your client formally becomes the
target of an impeachment inquiry does
not exactly scream confident cooperation
for the benefit of your client does it I
don't know that shut up [ __ ] totally
clears the president as Donald Trump
often likes to say so first of all I get
it this is not good for anyone and
everybody around Donald Trump is
panicking tensions are running extremely
high
the
other thing is that rudy guiliani could
actually end up being a far more
sinister player in all of this than
we've known up till now and i think that
in addition to an impeachment inquiry
into donald trump rudy giuliani should
be investigated because rudy guiliani is
the president's personal attorney and
what he's doing is traveling all around
the world lobbying on behalf of all
sorts of different interests
some of them foreign interests rudy
guiliani was involved in his lobbying
ukraine to smear joe biden that we know
at this point Rudy's admitted it and
Trump has admitted it Rudy Giuliani was
recently with Romanian leaders
criticizing anti-corruption efforts
going on there and there are immediately
questions about who is Rudy Giuliani
speaking for when he does this stuff
does he speak for the president does he
speak for the State Department is he
communicating anything that is an
official or a pseudo official position
for the US government the government has
clarified Rudy does not speak for them
but that actually raises even more
questions about who's paying Rudy
Giuliani for what he's doing is he
properly registered under farah for the
work that he is doing sometimes in the
interests of foreign governments it's
truly unheard of but that is the name of
the game here all of this stuff is not
okay the ukraine stuff the the
money-laundering alligator's this long
list of stuff but is anybody going to be
held accountable for it because that has
been the Trump experiment yeah this
stuff is not okay
but are they gonna do anything to us and
so far the system has not actually dealt
with what the president's administration
has been willing to do and unless that
changes they are getting away with all
of it let me know what you think about
all of this the wisdom of the
impeachment inquiry how Democrats should
carry it forward I want to hear from you
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the show is
on twitter at david pakman show and so
yesterday I said I was going to be live
streaming on Twitch I ended up
live-streaming on YouTube yesterday
tonight I am live streaming on twitch at
twitch.tv slash David Pakman
be talking about this and I hope to see
you there hey really quick I want to
tell you about one of our partners Finch
arrow watches giving our audience 15%
off everything they offer these guys are
awesome they craft really stylish
top-quality watches for both men and
women but they sell them at a fair price
unlike a lot of their competitors Vinci
row assembles their watches in small
batches which enables them to
meticulously ensure the quality of every
watch I personally wear of inch arrow
watch I don't like the idea of spending
thousands of dollars on a watch when I
can get a really excellent watch for a
hundred and fifty two hundred bucks
that's what I think is great about Vinci
row you get a watch made from top-notch
materials they look like watches that
you'd spend a ton of money on and
they're built like high-end watches
designed mechanically with longevity in
mind but you don't have to spend an arm
and a leg their entire goal is to make
watches of superior quality available to
the average person I just got a new one
called the Kairos I got the white and
silver version it looks great I've
gotten a ton of compliments they have a
huge variety of style so it was easy to
find one that fits my tastes there are a
bunch of other companies out there
selling watches at similar prices but a
lot of them look very cookie cutter and
just don't offer the same level of
craftsmanship as what you get from bench
arrow you're not going to find a better
maid watch at this grade of a price
they've got a watch for any type of look
you're trying to go for formal more
casual the straps and colors are
interchangeable so you can customize
your watch to your own preference and
you can get 15% off everything in their
store when you go to david pakman.com
slash watch and use the code Pakman at
checkout